الواحد من الكود دراسه
وحزب العظمه اليهوديه برئاسه هيثمرين الى
اتفاق ائتلاف اولي مهد الطريقه لتوقيع
المزيد من الملابس فقط
وسيتولى بنجفير حقيبه الامن القومي مع
صلاحيات واسعه تشمل اداره الشرطه حراسه
الحدود في الضفه الغربيه المحتله ويمنح
الاتفاق حزبه مناصبه تشمل صلاحياتها
المستوطنه
اهلا بكم كنباك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما طبيعه ومضامينه وابعاد
الاتفاق الذي توصل اليه حزب النقود في
الزعامه نتنياهو مع حزب العظمه اليهودي
لزعامه اثمار بن جفير بشان ملامح الحكومه
المرتقبه وسياساتها
وما هي الانعكاساته العمليه السياسيا
وامنيا لاتفاق بن كثير نتنياهو في ظل
التحذيرات محليا ودوليا من حكومه يمنيه
خالصه وكيف لتلك الاطراف ان تتعامل مع
الواقع الذي ستسعى تلك الحكومه لفرده
وانا مصير المشهد في المنطقه وعامه مسار
التسميه في المرحله المقبله واي خيرت
مطروحه على الجهات المعنيه به رفضا او
قبولا
[موسيقى]
يعزز المخاوف من حكومه المرتقبه قيل انها
ستكون
الاكثر يمينيه والاكثر تشددا في تاريخ
اسرائيل بعد ان اخفق في عقد صفقه مع حزب
الصهيونيه الدينيه بسبب التنازع مع زعيمه
بشان حقيبه الدفاع غير زعيم اللقود
وجهاته نحو حزب العظم اليهوديه ورئيسه
المثير للجدل اسمر
مقدمه له حقيبه من الداخليه بما تتضمنه
هذه الحقيبه من صلاحيات امنيه واسعه اضافه
الى مواقع اقتصاديه وامنيه اخرى حساسه
تشمل هي الاخرى ملف الاستيطان في الضفه
الغربيه
هكذا اقتربت المخاوف من ان تصبح واقعا
ومرحله سياسيه جديده
في حكومه
سيستاثر فيها نتنياهو بحقائب الماليه
والخارجيه والدفاع سيتولى بنجفير حقيبه من
الداخليه مع صلاحيات واسعه تشمل اداره
الشرطه حرس الحدود في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله كما ستسند الى حزمه وزاره تطوير
الجليل والنقب والمنع الوطني كما سيحصل
حزب العظمه اليهوديه على رئاسه لجنه الامن
الداخليه بالكنيسه ونائب وزير الاقتصادي
وكان من جفير قد وصل الى اتفاق المبدئيا
حول الخطوط العريضه للحكومه الجديده تضمن
التسويه الوضع القانوني ل 55 بؤره
الاستيطانيه عشوائيه
وفي تعليقه على الاتفاق على اثمار بن كفير
ان حزب العظمه اليهوديه حصل على الادوات
اللازمه لاعاده الامن
للاسرائيليين والاهتمام بالسكان في الجليل
والنقب والضواحي واضاف من جفير ان الوقت
قد حان للاعلان عن اقامه حكومه يمنيه
خالصه في اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من حيث
الكاتب المحلل السياسي الاسرائيلي
ضيوفنا الاخرين في الجزء الثاني من هذه
الحلقه اهلا بك
يعني حقيبه امنيه ومناصب امنيه واقتصاديه
وصلاحيات واسعه تشمل ملفات كالاستيطان هل
حصل على كل ما يريد
بكل تاكيد هذا ما كان يسعى اليه بنت منذ
البدايه وهنا يجب الانتباه هو يتحدث عن
وزاره الامن القومي فبينما عاده نتحدث
الامن القومي يعني مسالخ ل اييي دوله ماء
تجاه جيرانها هنا المفروض هو ليس اتجاه
الجيران ليس المصالح القوميه بمعنى
الاستراتيجيه العليا وانما اتجاه
الفلسطينيين
بان يكون مسؤول عن ما يجري في المناطق
الفلسطينيه لهذا السبب يعني تحت مسؤوليته
ستكون سرايا حرس الحدود في دفع الغربيه
هو الشخص الذي دائما كان معني بالقدوم الى
المسجد الاقصى بشكل روتيني حاليا مسؤول عن
كل القوات الامن في هذه المنطقه ايضا
داخليا اسرائيليا مسؤول عن قوات الشرطه
بالم كان كانوا يسمونه هذه الوزاره وزاره
الشرطه بعد ذلك لمن الداخلي الان للامن
القومي وكله بهدف الاستلاع على قوات الامن
واقامه ايضا ميليشيات وجماعات مسلحه مدنيه
او شبه مدنيه
صلاحيات بخيث انه لا تكون موجوده في وزاره
الدفاع او الامن وانما تكون منقسمه ما بين
وزاره الدفاع والجيش من جهه وزاره الامن
القومي من جهه الثانيه ولماذا لانه بينذر
معني بتغيير الواقع في الدقه
هو يغير اولا كل ما يتعلق بالرخص لاقامه
مستوطنات جديده وترخيص المستوطنات القائمه
وايضا هو نفس الشخص الذي يتحدث
كل العرب بمعنى هو لا يتحدث عن تدخل كلهم
ولكن
جزء منهم وايضا اعدام او يعني
عقوبه الموت ااه لمن هم
المخالدين
يعني بتغيير الواقفي ما بين اسرائيل
وفلسطينيين
وكل الوسائل ستكون متاحه امامه في وزاره
الامن القومي
[موسيقى]
انه ربما لانه فشل في استماله حزب
الصهيونيه الدينيه وبالتالي لم يكن امام
مخيره اخر
نعم همم اعتقد انه نتناول ما عملت في ذلك
ولماذا لانني نتنياهو يريد في المرحله
القادمه ان يسوق نفسه كاكثر اعتدالا من
بنت وشركاه الاخرين في الحكومه فهو بحاجه
اليهم داخل الحكومه لكي يقول الغرب ولا
الدول العربيه ولكل من يريد ان يسمع انه
يحاول ان يحافظ عليهم ويحاول ان تكون
الامور اكثر اعتداءا هو سيكون العنصر
الاكثر الاعتدالا
وداخليا سيؤثر ساعتها وسيكون فاضي لان
يؤثر على ما يحدث داخليا هو يريد الغاء
يعني لديه خطا خطط اخرى تتعلق بمحاكمته
وفي نظام القضاء المستقيل حتى الان
خطر يعني حتى وزير الدفاع السابق ان البنك
كثير يشكل خطرا على امن اسرائيل
نعم هي حركات يجب ان نقول يعني انه بندر
يمثل شرائح واسعه في الجمهور الاسرائيلي
يعني هذه هدول الناس موجودين يعني ليس بين
دير لحاله هو حذياب شعبيه كبيره جدا لا
احد يستطيع ان ينقذ ذلك وكل من يعتقد عكس
ذلك انه يجب الحفاظ على الديمقراطيه يجب
الحفاظ او السعد نحو حل سياسي مع طارق
فلسطيني اصلا يتحدث عنهم هناك بعض العرب
موجودين في هذه البلاد يجب معالجه القضيه
بحيث انه يعني كما كما قال ترحيل بعدها مش
كلهم
همم
شكرا همم لك همم المحلله الاسرائيلي كنت
معنا من حيفا
والان ولتعميق النقاش ينضم الينا من غزه
الدكتور صالح العاني الخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه ومن سان فرانسيسكو الدكتور
استاذ الامن الدولي
والسياسه الخارجيه في جامعه سان فرانسيسكو
اهلا بكما دكتورح النعامي يعني
بناءا على ما سمعته من الضفه الاسرائيلي
من همم
ما الذي
سيحدثه كتغيير وجود بن كثير في هذه
الحكومه
في حكومه
يعني اول اول استاذه خديجه علينا ان يعني
نذكر المشاهدين بمن هو ثمار بين كبير هو
اا عضو سابق في منظمه كاخه التي دشنها
الحقام كهانه وهذه المنظمه الارهابيه كانت
تدعو صراحه الى طرد الفلسطينيين الى الدول
العربيه
كان يقود بنفسه حتى العام الماضي حملات
تنكيل ضد الفلسطينيين في كل انحاء الضفه
الغربيه وفي داخل ال 48 وتحديدا في الخليل
لذلك شرطه الاحتلال التي الان سيصبح
مسؤولا عنها قدمت ضده 53 لائحه التهام
ممارسه العنف والتحيض عليه تمر بين كبير
كان يعلق سوره الارهابي همم جولد شتين
الذي نفذ مجزره الحرم المسجد الابراهيمي
في العام 1994
البرنامج السياسي لحركه المناعه اليهوديه
او اعظم اليهوديه كما يقولون يدعو صراحه
ليس كما قال ستيرن لانه معني بطرد جزء من
العرب يعني همم تشجيع كل العرب بينها
الائين طبعا الفلسطينيين في 48 فالظافر
الغربيه وقطاع غزه الى الى الدول العربيه
لذلك عندما يتولى هذا الشخص هذا المنصب
بهذه الصلاحيات الواسعه وتقريبا المطلقه
على اجهزه امنيه يعني همم ذا تاثير كبير
وذات قدره على الاحتكاك مع الفلسطينيين في
الضفه الغربيه 48 نحن نتحدث يعني عن عن عن
تحول يشبه الى حد كبير همم تشكيل ال- ال-
النازيه ايام هتلر منظمه الاس اي التي
كانت رضيف شبه عسكري للنازيه في تطبيق
برامج
بشكل صارع صريح وواضح عن مساله اللي هو
همم فرض حكم الاعدام هو يريد ان يغير
اوامر اطلاق النار يعني لاحظ الان هو
مسؤول عن شرطه حرس الحدود المسؤول عن
احتكاك المباشر في فلسطين ب 48 في الضفه
الغربيه في المسجد الاقصى وهو يقول بشكل
واضح يجب تغيير اوامر اطلاق النار بمعنى
بحيث يعني يمنح الجنود الضباط حريه مطلقه
في اطلاق النار وتسبب في قاتل اكبر عدد من
فلسطين ثم يعد بتمرير قانون يمنع هؤلاء
الحصانه لذلك نحن نتحدث عن تغيير كبير
وهائل في بيئه الصراع اكثر من ذلك وايضا
سيحصل همم على وزاره ما يسمى النقاب
والجليد نعم طيب
جميل انك عرفتنا على هذه الشخصيه
بمواصفاتها التي ذكرتها كان في منظمات كاخ
قاده اقتحمت المسجد الاقصى هو معه والهنا
السؤال طبعا البروفيسور 7 جون هو مع توسيع
الاستيطان مع تهجير اهالي النقب مع اقامه
المدارس الدينيه وهو شخصيه متطرفه جدا كيف
تنظر واشنطن الى اتفاق معها الشخص من هذا
بهذه المواصفات
اتفاق ثاني ياهو مع ابن كثير
طالما كان دائما قويا جدا للحكومه
الاسرائيليه
من السياسات الاسرائيليه لا يتفق معها
الامريكان
وقد قال بايضا من اي خلافات اسرائيل ينبغي
التعامل معها خلف ابواب مغلقه اي انه لا
يعلنها ولكن ولي اول مره
قالت بانهم
لن يتعاونوا معهم كثير
وقد قالوا بان هذا قد يضر العلاقات
الاسرائيليه الامريكيه وايضا قالوا بانهم
حاولوا جهدا كبيره للواق لمنعه وصول الى
هذا المنصب ولكن والان قد حصل على هذا
الموقع المسؤول عن الامن وقومي المهم فعلى
اداره وبعدين ان تقرر هل لانها تفعل اي
شيء اجزائه ام هذه ستكون مجرد كلمات دون
تطبيق
واضح من كلامك لا ينظر اليه بعين الرضا من
طرف الاداره الامريكيه وان المسؤولين
الامريكيين قالوا مسبقا انهم لم يتعاملوا
مع ابن كثير
[موسيقى]
حاو- مانشستر
تاثير ذلك على العلاقات بشكل عام مع
اسرائيل هذا امر مطروح كسؤال مثلا اداره
بيدن قد تتعاون فقط مع الوزارات الاخرى في
الحكومه ولا
وتتجنب بن غفير ولكن تواصل دعم السياسات
الاسرائيليه بشكل عام ولكن
انتقادات متزايده داخل الولايات المتحده
وخاصه
الديمقراطي حوله ما تقوم به الحكومه
الاسرائيليه والسياساتها
الاداره يقولون
المشكله الرئيسيه فيه انه سيقدم دعم
للعناصر المعاديه لاسرائيل انه يشجع همم
المشاعر المعاديه لاسرائيل داخل الحزب
الديمقراطي وهذا ما
يدورناهم اذا
قد تكون مشكله في العلاقات العامه اكثر ما
هي علاقه مشاكل
سياسيه حول وجود مثل هذه الشخصيات
الامريكيه لاحقا لكن كان نعود با الى
الدكتور صالح النعامي في غزه
فلسطينيا كيف سيتم التعامل معه مع نتانيا
وحكومته المقبله في ظل وجود همم
ومش فقط السلطه الفلسطينيه السلطه
الفلسطينيه وايضا الفصائل الفلسطينيه
خصوصا الفصائل المنخرطه في المقاومه
المسلحه دكتور
يعني انا في تقديري هذا سيكون تحديا كبيرا
بالنسبه للفلسطينيين وفي نفس الوقت فرصه
هائله الان بالنسبه لتحدي واضح تماما انه
شخص مثل اعتمار بن كبير يتبنى الانجليزي
التي تعرضت لها في السؤال الاجابه على
السؤال الاول واضح تماما انه هذا سيغير
بيئه الصراع يعني تخيلي عندما يقوم اتمار
بين كبير بمنح يعني تطبيق تعهداته في
الحمل الانتخابيه ومنح تعليمات بتغيير
اوامر اطلاق النار مثلا في المسجد الاقصى
يعني يصبح ايتها اي محاوله للشرطه لفك همم
لمواجهه ال- ال- المعتصمين في المسجد
الاقصى تتحول الى مذبحه وهذا ايضا ينطبق
في منظف الغربي وهذه الطبق ايضا في داخل
48 نحن نتحدث عن تغيير بيئه بيئه متخصصه
بعدين يتمر كبير وقال ذلك في الحمله
الانتخابيه بشكل واضح وصريح بانه يعني
سيصر على الغاء اتفاقيات اوصل وحل السلطه
الفلسطينيه قال ذلك ويكرره باستمرار لذلك
اذا اخذنا بعين الاعتبار انه اصلا السلطه
الفلسطينيه الان تعاني كما حتى يحذر
الاسرائيليون واداره بايدون من ترقي
قدرتها على السيطره في الضفه الغربيه فان
هذا صعود اتمار بن كبير والتصعيد الهائل
من ناحيه امنيه ومن ناحيه عسكريه ضد همم
ضد همم ضد الفلسطينيين سيقلص قدره السلطه
الفلسطينيه على على على الاستمرار وبكل
تاكيد سينزع مقومات استمرار التعاون الامن
مع ما بينها وما بين اسرائيل الان فيما
يتعلق همم
بالفصائل الفلسطينيه الفصائل المقاومه انا
في تقديري انه هذا يعني يمنح فرصه لانه
الان يصبح يعني بشكل واضح وصريح بالمناسبه
الحكومات الاسرائيلي من 48 حتى الان ما
رست اكبر بكثير مما ي- يعني يقوله ثمار
ومن خلفه همم افضع مما يبشر به اثمار لكي
اكتمار بن كبير يقول هذا بشكل صريح واضح
ويريد ان يدرس هذا في حتى في في البرنامج
السياسي للحكومه الاسرائيلي القادمه لذلك
هذا يمنح فرصه لتوحيد السحاب ساحات
المقاومه الفلسطينيه الان ويصبح يعني يلغى
المسوغات الجدل اللانهائي من بين
الفلسطينيين حول مساله التسويه وما هي
الحياه ال- ال- الحلول الامثل لمواجهه هذا
المحتل الان يبيت بشكل واضح وصريح لانه ما
صارت تسويه قد يعني استنفذ وانه لا خيار
امام الفلسطيني في كل ساحات وجدهم الا
مواجهه هذا المحتل
7 قبل قليل قلت ان خطوره همم كثير تتعدد
داخل الاسرائيلي الى المشهد الامريكي
والتوازنات بين الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين
كيف ذلك
الديمقراطي
شديد بشكل متزايد حول موضوع فلسطين
والاسرائيل الرئيس فايدل بشكل عام كان
يدعم يدعم موقف قوي مؤيد لاسرائيل لكن
هناك ديمقراطيون يا شباب في الكونغرس
وخاصه ضمن الجمهور بشكل عام يدعمون بشكل
اكثر الفلسطينيين او او يعتقدون على
اسرائيل
قوي في الحكومه الاسرائيليه هذا سي السيد
ان تكون اكثر انتقادا
لاسرائيل لما كانت عليه في السابق
وعلى ذلك
النقاشات والانقسامات داخل الحزب
الديمقراطي حول ما ينبغي عليه السياسه
الامريكيه اذا اسرائيل وفلسطين ولكن ربما
تكون الولايات المتحده منشغله الان بالحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا
واوروبا ما لا يندرج هذا ضمن الاولوياتها
في هذه المرحله همم انتقل اليك دكتور صالح
النعامي في غزه همم
اعتقد ان هذه الحكومه القادمه تمتلك برايك
الصلابه الكافيه للبقاء بهذه التشكيله
التي دخلها بنت كثير مع وزاره الامن
القومي ام انها ربما يعني مندوره بالسقوط
الان علينا
القوه التي تمثل اقصى اليمين الديني في
اسرائيل
محاكمه في ثلاثه قضايا
فساد خطيره تلقى الرشوه خيانه الامانه
الاحتيال وهذه القضايا في حال دين فيها في
النهايه فهو يعني سيصدر بحقه حكم بسجل قد
لمده طويله لان ما المخرج
من هذا من هذا من هذا المقال وحتى يحافظ
على ارثهك كشخص الذي امض اطول فتره حكم في
تاريخ اسرائيل هو قانون ما يسمى قانون هد
جبروت او قانون التغلب القانون الذي يلغي
صلاحيات همم
صلاحيات المحكمه العليا وبالتالي يمنح نعم
شكرا حصانه من المحاكمه من الذي مستعد ان
يعطيها لك نعم باختصار قوه الامير الدين
هي التي ستمنحه القدره طيب باختصار شديد
همم ستيفن جونس هل يمكن ان يستغلني ثاني
هو اسرائيل انشغال واشنطن كما ذكرت من قبل
حرب روسي على اوكرانيا في هذا الملف
تحديدا في هذا الموضوع
باختصار لو سمحت بالتاكيد سيحاول ان يقوم
بذلك ولكن الولايات المتحده لا يمكن ان
تتجاهل فلسطين واسرائيل تماما
والشرق الاوسط بشكل عام ما زالت في غايه
الاهميه الامريكيه
شكرا جزيلا لكما صالح النعامي من غزه
وايضا ضيفنا من سان فرانسيسكو البروفيسور
7 جونس شكرا جزيلا لكما
وبهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر لكم منه اطيب المنى والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]